you know Prime mve behind open AI in the
sense that it was created because of
discussions that I had with Larry pagee
um back when he and I were were friends
in st's house and I talked to about AI
safety and and Larry did not care about
AI safety or at least at the time he
didn't um you know and at one point he
called me a specious for being pro-human
and I'm like well what team are you on
Larry uh still on team robot be and I'm
like okay so at the time you know uh
Google Google had had acquired deep mind
they had uh probably two-thirds of all
AI res you know probably two3 of all the
AI researchers in the world MH they had
basically infinite money and
compute and the guy in
charge you know Larry pagee did not care
about safety and even yelled at me um
and and called me a specious
being pro human so I don't know if you
know about humans they can change their
mind and maybe you and Larry paig can
still can be friends once more I'd like
to be friends with Larry again um he
he's he he got really the the the
breaking of the friendship was over open
AI um and
specifically um I think the the key
moment was recruiting ilas Sky um so I
love he's so brilliant il's good good
human uh smart good heart
um and um that was that was a tough
recruiting
battle um it was mostly Demis on one
side and me on the other both trying to
recruit IIA and Ilia went back and forth
you know was going to stay at Google he
was going to leave then he was going to
stay then he would leave and and finally
he he did agree to join open AI that was
one of the toughest recruiting battles
we ever had and but that that was really
the the Lynch pin for opening I being
successful and I was you know also
instrumental and recruiting a number of
other people and I provided all the
funding in the
beginning um over $40
million um and the
name the the open and opening ey is
supposed to mean open source and it was
created as a nonprofit open source and
now it is a closed source for maximum
profit which I think it's not good
comma but like we talked about with war
and leaders talking I do hope that
there's only a few folks working on this
at the highest level I do hope you
reinvigorate friendships here like I
said I'd like to be friends again with
Larry I haven't seen him in ages um and
we were friends for a very long time I
met I met Larry Page before he got
funding for Google or actually I guess
before he got Venture funding I think it
he got the first like 100k from from I
think be time or someone um it's wild to
think about all that happened and you've
guys known each other that whole time
just 20 years yeah since maybe 98 or
something yeah it's crazy crazy how much
has happened since then yeah 25
years a lot of happen
insane